foreign
[Music]
Lord's podcast
welcome to the Lord's minute our quick
hit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
Beyond I'm your host Ty Swenson writer
for Lords of gaming and with me again is
Lord King
She-Hulk attorney at law has finally
smashed its way on to Disney plus
featuring the story of how Jennifer
Walters becomes an official member of
the Hulk family
we get a little backstory quickie with
Jennifer Walters getting an accident
with uh
your body and crazy oh
there's no no sound ah there you go and
now it's body
[ __ ]
Blue Line
is this the light colors
that's a soft Delight
hard light here
all right it's showing that my
connection is stable Giggles wow okay
all right let's try that again you
didn't hear when you was biting no okay
so if you see me do this yeah that'll
let you know
welcome to the Lord's minute our quick
kit video series where we talk about all
the biggest happenings in gaming and
Beyond I'm your host Ty Swenson writer
for Lords of gaming and with me today is
Lord King
She Hulk attorney at law has smashed its
way on to Disney plus featuring the new
origin story of Jennifer Walters and how
she becomes an official member of the
Hulk family the premiere episode kicked
off with some backstory and her training
montage with none other than Bruce
Banner on how to come to grips with
being a Hulk it's okay I'm gonna pass it
to you with this origin story for
She-Hulk in the MCU it's slightly
different than her traditional coming of
age in the comics how do you think they
handle that it's hugely different you
know in the books uh she was on the run
from the mob because she was Prosecuting
the mob and she got shot and uh her bro
um her cousin uh David Bruce Banner
Robert Bruce Banner whichever uh name
that you want to use you know depending
on the books or the TV show uh he
happened to be there and while he was
there he gave her uh impromptu
transfusion like like he's a
phlebotomist but anyway
um doctor's a doctor right
um I love I love books and uh she became
the Savage She-Hulk uh in this
um
let me back it up a minute let me back
it up a minute because I think I'm
getting really ahead of myself the fact
that they introduced her breaking the
fourth wall
inside off the bat right off the bat
they this
um that ushers in Deadpool
that conditions the audience to a right
now
um we have other characters that will
break the fourth wall she was the
original character to break the fourth
wall besides Howard the Duck you know
Howard the Duck did it but Howard the
Duck is a lesser known book so we're
going to talk about the books that are
are more known and she was like a more
known character and
she constantly broke the fourth wall you
know John Byrne is one of my favorite
artists and when he got uh control of
her books uh because he was doing uh she
was doing a Savage Seahawk at first and
then uh when John Byrne got there and he
did Sensational She-Hulk
he revolutionized her he turned Jennifer
Walters into a sex symbol she had this
long voluptuous hair like a Jersey girl
and she was uh leaning heavily into her
sexuality and what I see here is they
took all of it they took all of the
books and they took in the beginning
where she was uh but she you know got
the the blood droplets after the shikari
ship comes down and they cream off the
side of the road and you know she cuts
her arm and you sees a very deep cut and
you know um Bruce cuts his uh his what
was his head or his arm or something and
he bleeds into her womb and instantly
you saw the gamma
um take hold of her the gamma radiation
getting into her bloodstream and what uh
what Bruce said to explain to her is
that they have um
a certain genome uh and
I laughed because then that brings in
mutants right they're saying that they
have this x-gene that allows them to uh
absorb gamma radiation so
what he's explaining to you is if
Captain America did this this won't
happen
right if if Iron Man did this this will
not happen yeah this doesn't just happen
to any Joe Shmoop right so they happen
to have a a gene that's in their body
and they are compatible so this actually
happens because of that Gene and I I
love the fact that they hit different
notes going through this whole series
right in the first episode the hit on
the X-Men really quickly with telling
you that there's a gene type that that's
only specific to these to these two
individuals so far right and it could be
something else later on down the road
they break the fourth wall and it allows
you to know that there's going to be
other characters that's going to break
the fourth wall so don't be put off
and the fact that it's known that she's
a Hulk and people are comfortable around
her
that that within itself
takes away what Bruce had to go with his
whole life the people having fear of him
fear of the monster and they they are
automatically show you that this
character is completely different than
the Hulk when he put his big book down
and he's like this is how we're going to
study this and and this is what we're
going to do
he's like this year is 15 years
and and in matter of
hours
she had her Transformations under
control
and it it leans into maybe uh because
she's not as strong as the Hulk
she has different powers she can
manipulate gamma radiation in a way that
uh he can't he can she can control her
uh um her rage and be in control of the
She-Hulk what he asked or what Bruce
asked her is there somebody else inside
your head
and she was like no it's just me so for
a lot of things that he was wrestling
with and they showed you the difference
between the two where he feels that he
has to be an isolated monster and she
wants to integrate right back into
society like no I am not going to shut
my life off no I'm not gonna stop doing
what I want to do I want to be a lawyer
I want to do this stuff I do not have to
be on this island away from everybody
and everything that I love this is not
the way that you're supposed to live and
she gives him a different perspective I
don't know how that perspective plays
with the Hulk but
how it plays with the character going
forward you understand that she is going
to be in society and the fact that she
gave you the quick backstory and then
gets into the um the the the courtroom
and Titania
one of her number one foes like they
made this character up just for the the
pure purpose of being uh um one of her
signature foes because you know the Hulk
has the Abomination Spider-Man has Doc
Ock in his Rogue Gallery you know and so
on and so on so she needed a character
and it was very good that this character
showed up in the first episode and it
was it was just more stuff around but it
was just so many nuggets and bits and
pieces and they leaned heavy into the
books I love that fact I love the fact
that they looked at the books and
grabbed the source material and didn't
shy away from it and didn't hold your
hand this is this is fantastic stuff I
know I talked a lot it's been a week
that I've been holding in some bottle
and stuff and it was my fault that we
were like but go ahead sorry oh no
worries I really liked how
we got a bunch of different nuggets on
um a lot of different things that's
happening currently in the MCU and have
in the past
um mainly how Bruce over the years has
been coming to grips with being a Hulk
and um accepting the fact that he feels
he has this responsibility he tells
Jennifer straight up like no you don't
get that's not how it works people like
you and me we have been bestowed this
great duty to society and Jennifer's
like that's cool bro but that ain't me
like I got a job nine to five to get
back to
um and that during Bruce's isolation and
dealing with the depression and the
mental illness that Tony was actually
there for him uh and in a big way he um
helped get him a nice spot on this
island away from people helped build a
bar drinking buddy a person to vent to
um camaraderie like that that we didn't
really know even after the departure of
Tony from the Limelight in the MCU we're
still getting these bits of nuggets of
how he really impacted that unit
Universe
um
and like you said I'm really interested
in the series moving forward their take
on Jennifer Walters and what she can
bring to the table and that she has a
multifaceted
um personality when it comes to being a
She-Hulk and Bruce sees it as like you
know super dangerous if even one small
thing goes wrong like that's it like we
gotta play it by the book literally this
is how it's supposed to go and
Jennifer's like like look we are
different people I understand you had to
deal with this and I'm sorry but like
I don't need to be a prisoner obviously
I don't need to go through the same hoop
Hoops that you did and you trying to
relate your experience to mine is
necessarily one to one and then they use
the opportunity to translate to the
difference the difference is that say a
woman in society goes through compared
to someone who's not a woman also
translated well and I loved how when
Jennifer went on that rant to say like
yo I gotta deal with keeping my emotion
checks on a daily basis I mean cat
called being underestimated because if I
don't I could be murdered just for who I
am and that wasn't and and she finished
that thought and she didn't say that
she had it rougher or that her
experience or whatnot is comparably
better than Bruce's it's just different
and that's what she wanted Bruce to know
like you know we're still family the
other day but we our lives are
fundamentally different even though we
are now both hulks yeah I love the fact
that you had the battle of the estrogen
versus the testosterone
um that was really cool uh the fact that
you know he he felt away because she was
doing things a little bit easier than
him and a lot of things come easier you
know to to females as as raising
children
I can attest that girls are faster at
picking up things than guys I can tell
you I I see it yeah I'm just like it is
what it is and he had that he learned
that on a very fundamental basis in in
front of him so it was really cool that
she was doing all the stuff and he was
like okay we have to Namaste we have to
do this other stuff and she's running
circles around and she's like I'm
killing it I can get out of here I can
get up out of here
and you know he they got aggressive and
she pretty much hold her own with him
when he did the the Thunderclap you know
Hulk is just pure Brute Force but she's
finesse and force and
also later on I want to know if they're
going to touch on the aspect because
being that she's a lawyer being that she
does stay in some form of shape she
takes karate classes and she really
excels in her karate later on and she
uses that because remember she's
Jennifer Walter she is the the She-Hulk
she's able to use those moves in her
combat style when she fights something
completely different right than the Hulk
the Hulk was just brute force and she
doesn't well there is another certain
lawyer that's supposed to make an
appearance I don't know that'll be a
tie-in at all but I can't wait I can I
cannot wait for episode two because I
know they and I tried to shy away from
looking and peeking to see what's coming
up next right you know um
there's a certain Abomination an old
creature that's gonna show up and
they've been using him more like they
used him uh in what was that uh Shang
Chi and you know we we saw what was
going on with him and Wong I want to
know what's going to happen more because
Huang seems to be this Advocate why are
you the advocate for this guy what's
going on here I want to know more about
that Dynamic and it seems like Wong is
going to be in the next episode because
Wong is going to explain a couple of
things to clear up that that part
because that was left so hanging out
there so ambiguous that we just didn't
understand what it was so we're going to
get some answers to that but I can't
wait Yep this stuff it just seems like
these guys just keep getting better and
better because we're off of Miss Marvel
we from Moon Knight to Miss Marvel to
this and it seems like they found their
stride on their TV shows and they're
hitting it on every cylinder and I
really love it I really love it yeah
yeah I can't wait uh to see how She-Hulk
unfold moving forward because like King
says they're they're really pumping them
out in a great fashion and it just feels
like we're in a golden age or a
Renaissance of comic book characters
coming to life in this medium
but that has been the Lord's minute
thank you so much for joining us we're
here every Monday Wednesday and Friday
at Lords of gaming.net I'm ty Swenson
here with Lord King and this has been
the Lord's minute peace
[Music]
thank
you